Well, good morning church.
It is the end of a series.
And so, uh, this, this was something
that I started back when I first began preaching about 12
years ago at our first church.
I went through the book of Ephesians in 26 sermons.
And so I felt like I needed to honor
that at the end of the sermon series.
And so just began dressing up
and it's a fun thing that four of you have participated in
so far and so excited for that.
Thanks for that. Uh, yeah, so anyway,
we're gonna keep doing it for the next 30
years, so just get used to it.
Um, but I do wanna give you a quick update
from the elders as well.
As we mentioned previously, we're planning for August
to begin teaching through, uh, what we believe about roles
of women in ministry at Henderson Hills.
And as we included a diverse team
of women along the process in our discussions, we realized
that our positions needed further explanation.
And so we are going to continue working on clarifying that.
And, and our goal is so we can clearly articulate
how every man and every woman in our church can flourish.
And so we want to get that right, excited for that,
have a full position paper
and a teaching associated with that coming hopefully soon.
And so that's just an update for you there.
Uh, today though, as we get into our final parable, uh, one
of my favorite activities at our kids' school is
for the fifth graders every year they take them garage
sailing on a Friday in May.
And so it's just fun in general, right?
Traveling around three hours out there.
But, but the class integrates some financial instruction
along the way as well because they give each one
of the students $5 to spend at the garage sale
and they want them to come back with something in,
in special ways.
And so funny to see what the kids value
and what they think in their mind is worth something.
And so, uh, this kid comes back with an old picture frame
and it's a box of AV cables, right?
Just that all that's left.
And this one comes back with an old sleeve
of tennis balls from 1975.
Like who, who knows what that value is, but,
but it's just fun to watch and see how that plays out.
But, but think about what might happen if
that fifth grader gets the $5 and,
and they ride around all morning
and they go look at all the garage sales
and they, they see everything
and then when they get back to school, they take the $5
and they hand it back to their teacher.
Now she would look at him funny
and be like, what, what, what are you doing?
'cause the point of the exercise was to
invest the $5 in the pursuit
of finding something more valuable.
Now, of course, the the the school, we get the $5 back,
put it back into petty cash, okay, great.
But remember her instruction was to take the $5
and turn it into something even better.
That means really there was no way of failing.
You couldn't get an F on the assignment.
You just would need to spend the money
and see what you get back and bring it back
and show the only way to fail would be to not even try,
just 'cause you didn't wanna lose it, didn't wanna waste it.
You brought it back. You know,
actually we're gonna see a very similar idea in the parable
of the Minas today in Luke chapter 19.
So take your copy of God's word
and turn there with me to Luke 19
for the final time in the Book of Luke for now,
Luke chapter 19 verses 11 through 27 is
where we're gonna see this parable.
Now I said it's the parable of the Minas
and we're not really familiar with that term.
I'll explain it in a moment. Some of you might be familiar
with the parable of the talents
that's over in Matthew chapter 25.
It's very similar in the way that they're set up
and the way they talk about things.
But there's slight differences
that we'll see, especially here.
And so when, when we look at that Matthew
and Luke, were they recording the same event,
like the same speech Jesus gave
or were there different occasions they
heard these varieties?
We don't know exactly,
but what we do know is
that this is gonna challenge us today.
God's word will challenge us.
'cause remember what Jesus was doing with the parables?
He was dividing,
he was separating people in the kingdom mentality.
So he was asking the question with every parable,
are you a kingdom citizen or not?
Are you in or are you out?
Are you gonna live according to the kingdom or are you not?
This one will be very, very clear about how that works out.
I wanna read verse 11 just to start with,
because it provides the context for the parable.
Luke 19 verse 11, as they heard these things, he proceeded
to tell a parable because he was near to Jerusalem and
because they suppose that the kingdom of God was
to appear immediately.
Okay? So what are these things that they heard?
Who were they? They were the disciples.
Most likely those committed to Jesus.
But, but what are these things that they heard
which prompted Jesus
to then tell the parable that we're about to study?
Well, it's the account right
before this, the account of Jesus with Zacchaeus.
Remember who Zacchaeus was that that we little man
climbed up in a sycamore tree for the Lord?
He wanted to see when the Savior passed that way,
he looked up in the tree
and he said, Zacchaeus, you come down.
I'm going to your house.
Okay, so if you're completely lost,
that's an old Sunday school song.
Many of us grew up in church.
We're like, oh yeah, that clearly matches.
But that's how we know the story, right? It, it matches.
It's exactly right. But that that's
what happened in the scene was not just
that Jesus interacted with this guy in the tree.
It was that Jesus totally changed
this rebellious tax collector's life
from darkness to light, death to life.
Verses eight and nine, look up at it.
Jesus said what he said to Zacchaeus.
And Zacchaeus stood
and said to the Lord, behold, Lord, the half
of my goods I give to the poor, if I've defrauded anyone
of anything, I restore it fourfold.
That's repentance, right?
And Jesus said to him, today, salvation has come
to this house since he also is a son of Abraham,
meaning this, this rebellious turncoat.
He's welcome in the kingdom of God by faith.
Then Jesus gives his his mission statement, his thesis.
Verse 10, for the son of man, that's Jesus, the son
of man came to seek and to save the lost.
That's what the disciples had just heard.
They heard these things
and what their minds then immediately went to verse 11 says,
was they suppose Now the kingdom of God was imminence.
Like we heard, we watched this with Zacchaeus.
We heard what Jesus said that the son of man, that's,
that's a kingdom idea.
That's a prophecy idea. Okay? The kingdom of God is coming.
He's gonna save the lost.
This must be the time that kingdom is coming. It is now.
It's imminent. 'cause they knew the promises,
they knew the prophets were the ones
who predicted when the kingdom of God showed up,
the lost were gonna be saved,
creation was gonna be restored, knew life was gonna come.
That they saw this in, in Zia's story.
They were like, oh, this is it.
So they were expecting the Messiah.
They knew the Messiah was coming to bring this kingdom
to bear the previous 400 years
from what they had experienced in this moment, 400 years
before there was total silence from God.
But they still had those promises from
before that they knew that God had promised a messiah
to come and they were looking for the Messiah.
But here's the problem. Over those years,
the expectation of that Messiah had shifted to become more
of a political and military figure.
And they were looking for someone
to drive out the hated Roman empire,
to give God's people their land back exclusively.
And and through those 400 years, a couple people popped up
and it, it looked like they might be the one,
but then they were squashed.
And so they kept looking, kept looking and kept looking.
And this might be the one, not only that.
Did you see what verse 11?
Where was Jesus headed at this moment?
He was headed to Jerusalem, which was the capital
where the temple was, where kind of the, the seat
of everything like that was gonna be the place
where the Messiah came back
and was gonna destroy the hated Romans.
They were sure Jesus is going
to Jerusalem to win the victory.
That's why Jesus told the parable he wanted
to reorient their minds away from looking merely
for this earthly savior.
To something a little bit more though, immediately
after this, starting in verse 28, which is
after our parable today, immediately
after this they celebrated Jesus walking into Jerusalem,
the triumphal entry, you know palm
branches, hosanna, save us.
You are the the king who comes in the name of the Lord.
They're saying all of that.
But they failed to realize
that he was coming to Jerusalem to win an eternal victory
through his life, death and resurrection.
It wasn't to drive out the Romans, it was
to win the eternal victory over sin and darkness and death.
They missed it. They were not expecting that kind
of a triumph, that though they were expecting the Messiah,
they missed the fact
that they were actually seeing the king right now.
They were expecting the kingdom to come imminently
that this was gonna happen.
But they missed the fact that this was the king
right in front of them for three years.
The king was there who came
for a higher reason than what they had expected.
So Jesus, by telling this parable, he's dividing people
according to the kingdom that he says to them as you'll see,
that that kingdom that they're looking for is not merely
for their own comforts, just make their life better,
make it easier to live in the land.
That's not why the kingdom first and foremost came
because what Jesus says here is he actually shows the
kingdom of God is pretty demanding.
We will see it here that the kingdom they're looking
for is demanding.
In other words, what was this king coming to expect of us?
What was he requiring of kingdom citizens?
This is the parable verses 11 through 27.
As they heard these things, he proceeded to tell the parable
because he was near to Jerusalem
because they suppose the kingdom of God was
to appear immediately.
And he said, therefore a noble man went into a far country
to receive for himself a kingdom
and then return calling 10 of his servants.
He gave them 10 minas.
Now a min, let me explain what that is,
is about three months worth of income for a common laborer.
So just think we might imagine $8,000
for example, as an estimate.
So he gave 10 servants each one min.
And he said to them, engage in business until I come.
But his citizens hated him and sent a delegation
after him saying, we do not want this man to reign over us.
And when he returned having received the kingdom,
he ordered these servants to whom he had given the money
to be called to him that he might know
what they had gained by doing business.
The first came before him saying, Lord,
your min has made 10 minus more said to him, well done,
good servant because you've been faithful in a very little,
you shall have authority over 10 cities.
And the second came saying, Lord,
your min has made five minus.
And he said to him, you are to be over five cities.
And then another came saying, Lord, here's your minora,
which I kept laid away in a handkerchief for I was afraid
of you 'cause you're a severe man, you take
what you did not deposit you, reap what you did not sow.
And the king said to him, I
will condemn you with your own words.
You wicked servant. You knew that I was a severe man taking
what I did not deposit, reaping what I did not sow.
Why then did you not put my money in the bank And at my
coming I might have collected it with interest.
And he said to those who stood by, take the minor from him
and give it to the one who has the 10 minus.
And they said to him, Lord, he he already has 10 minus.
I tell you that to everyone who has more will be given,
but from the one who has not even
what he has will be taken away.
But as for these enemies of mine who did not want me
to reign over them, bring them here and slaughter them
before me, great
end to the parables right?
Now here's what's interesting about this parable
because if you really dig into it, you see
that there's actually two plot lines going
in the same parable.
They both have to do with this noble
man receiving a kingdom.
But there's first this group of just average citizens
who reject him as their king.
And then there's this group of 10 servants who are charged
with faithfully stewarding all
that the king is entrusted to them.
So they kind of run parallel, they mix a little bit, but it,
but in essence they're separate.
So we're gonna take 'em separately
and see what Jesus was doing with these.
And so first we, the challenge here,
what we learned from this first parable is
that we must welcome the king just base truth
as you dig into this, we must welcome the king.
So this wealthy man went into a far country to receive
for himself a kingdom and then return.
We might say that he was inaugurated as the king.
Well then how did those average citizens respond
to his inauguration?
Verse 14, his citizens hated him and sent a delegation
after him saying, we do not want this man to reign over us.
And then Jesus goes on, as Luke records it,
to talk a lot about stewardship and giving Minas
and receiving those back
and talking about rewards and everything.
And then that plot line shows up again down in verse
27 at the very end.
But as for these enemies of mine who did not want me
to reign over them, right, that's that group,
bring them here and slaughter them before me.
Alright, so just two verses essentially, right?
This, this parallel plot line is,
is really just two verses about this group of people and,
and they reject this man as their king.
He calls them his enemies and he has them destroyed.
That's it. Two verses you can't get around.
Like that's not complicated, it's straightforward.
So what do we do with that? What do we do with that?
A lot of people try to write that off and
and say, well that's not really what it means.
And all those things just symbolism, those kind of things.
But, but actually what this is is prophetic language
that is intended to shock us
and it's intended to spark some introspection
and some examination thinking about questions in my mind of
what this is saying.
And Luke's not the first person,
Jesus in the first person to do this.
This is all the way from the Old Testament prophets.
Like we'll see in the book of Micah starting next week
as we walk through the fall in Micah,
they use language like this intending people
to understand that there is a warning here
that they need to take seriously.
Like when that when that tornado siren goes off, it's,
it's not meant for you to just go about your normal life
when you hear that, I know
Saturdays at noon is different, okay?
But we're not talking about that. We're talking about like
when that thing goes off you just
keep playing the switch, right?
Is that no, you don't do that.
You're like, oh, I need to be aware of something that's
that's a problem potentially coming my way.
Let me look at my phone, let me look at the tv.
Let me understand what's happening right now.
Should I be worried? That's what this is.
It's a warning meant to spark something in our hearts
questions wonderings.
And so Jesus is doing that with this scene.
By the way, if this is merely symbolism, that means
what he's symbolizing is worse than what it actually is.
So if his enemies are slaughtered in front of him, like
what do you want that to be symbols for?
This is the tragedy of rejecting the king.
And now remember Jesus is talking about
the kingdom of God here.
So who's the king he's referring to here?
It's him that Jesus is the king and
and that's the question he's getting people to ask here.
As he tells this to the people around him, he says,
do you want me to reign over you or not?
It's basic simple.
Do you want me, are you willing to welcome me as your king
and all that that entails?
Do you want me to be your king or not?
So when we think about that today, the obvious application
of course is first for the unbeliever.
That if that's you and you have rejected Jesus as your king,
then we see the ramifications of that decision.
If he is the king, then you have no right
to shake your fist at him.
He is the king whether we want to believe that or not.
And the results of refusing him, rejecting him are tragic.
But there's a way to get into the kingdom, to be received
into his kingdom.
And the way you welcome the king is
through humble repentance.
That's what the, the word of God says repeatedly is.
The way that you come in is by repentance and faith.
That word repentance means a change of mind
and a change of direction that you turn from your sin
and yourself as the king and you turn to Jesus as your king.
And you say, that's done. I'm in for you.
You turn to the one now. Now this is, this is good news.
You turn to the one who was slaughtered for you,
which was predicted 700 years
before Jesus even came on the scene.
Isaiah 53 says that exact thing, it prophesies
that this messiah, this savior, he was pierced
for our transgressions, he was crushed for our iniquities.
Upon him was the chastisement that brought us peace
with his wounds.
We are healed. All of us like sheep have gone astray.
We've turned every one of us to our own way,
way which is sin rebellion.
And the Lord has laid on him the iniquity of us all.
That's Isaiah 53, 5 and six.
So you can't, you can't mindfulness
your way outta this problem.
You can't better behave your way out of this.
This is Jesus offering the solution to sin and rebellion.
It's humble repentance and faith in him.
So that's for you unbeliever.
That's that's this application.
But there's also an application here, even dealing
with welcoming the king for you believer.
See the nature of the entire parable is that there is a king
who is in charge.
There's a king who is reigning.
Yet the reality of the human ego
is that we can find nearly limitless reasons why no one
should reign over us.
No one can tell us what to do.
No one can correct me when I'm wrong.
Is that not innate, innate to us? Even as believers?
Like that's not immediately gone when you come
to Christ like that, that's still being
worked out of your soul.
Every single one of us.
So even us as believers must welcome the king
and his kingship over our lives.
How do we do that? Well, we're continually
repenting our lives as well.
But but humble commitment is
how we welcome the king over us in our lives as believers.
We must humbly commit to him as well
where he calls the shots, he directs traffic, he tells us
how to live our lives.
That's where we commit to king Jesus telling us
how to spend our money, telling us
how we, we invest our time,
telling us how we relate to people of the opposite sex
that he calls the shots on that that, that he's telling us
how we work, how we go to school, how we think,
how we speak.
He is in charge telling us all of that of we committed
to him as our king.
'cause that leads us directly into the second plot line
of this parable that those of us who have committed to him
as our king, we must not only welcome the king,
we must also steward his kingdom.
Then as a result, if we've committed to him as king,
we steward his kingdom.
Now that's our assignment.
'cause remember when Jesus was telling this parable,
he was illustrating not some new investment
strategy like how to make more money.
And that's what, that's no, that's not at all.
He's talking about the nature of his kingdom.
He's talking about kingdom business here.
He's saying here's how you invest your life for the kingdom
and here's what's gonna happen on the back end of that.
So when we look at this parable through that lens,
we clearly see our assignment right?
Our assignment is very clear from this parable.
And here's what I want you to see in this too.
This is not just for pastors and missionaries.
This parable, this kingdom assignment
was spoken to all of them right now.
He's telling this parable to all of us, not just those of us
who called into vocational ministry or or whatever.
Like yeah, that's your job. As your assignment is clear, no,
this is your assignment too believer if you've committed
to the king, the king says, here's how you go about this.
'cause remember he calls these 10 servants together
and he gives each one of them one minor, one sum of money.
And in verse 13 he says, explicitly engage in business
with it until I return.
And that word engage in business in the Greek,
the original language, it means put that money to work,
trade it, start using it
and trying to get a return on it, right?
He's, he expected the return when he came back.
That means the king did not leave those minas
merely for safekeeping.
He left them for investment
and two of the servants did well, but one did not.
So what did he leave for us today as his servants?
What did he leave for us to invest like this?
It's not money necessarily pure form like a min,
it's something else.
What did he leave? Well, first
and foremost, it's the message
and the values of the kingdom of God
that the king has come and has
provided a way for us to be reconciled to him
and thus reconciled to one another.
That's the message of the kingdom.
It's what second Corinthians five verses 18
through 20 says very clearly.
All this is from God who through Christ reconciled us
to himself, gave us the ministry
of reconciliation that is in Christ.
God was reconciling the world to himself,
not counting the trespasses against them, entrusting to us
the message of reconciliation.
Therefore we are ambassadors for Christ.
That's ambassadors like you've been entrusted with authority
by on behalf of your country to go to somebody else, right?
You are an ambassador. That's an entrusting idea.
Even more God making his appeal through us.
So now we're vessels of God's work, work in the world.
We implore you on behalf of Christ, be reconciled to God.
You see this entrusting language of the ministry
and message of reconciliation of the kingdom of God.
And so here's what that means, just base level.
That means that our job as believers
is not to try
and maintain some Christian subculture,
some Christian bubble like so we can live comfortably
and we can live safe and we can be in our little world
and we're all protected.
That's not the goal here.
Our job is to invest our lives
and to invest the principles of the kingdom for his purposes
out there, right?
I I think of people like George Mueller starting an
orphanage in the 18 hundreds.
I think of people like Hudson Taylor
who started the China Inland mission
going on mission, the 18 hundreds.
I think of John Wesley whose phrase just is such a
beautiful thing.
He's saying, the world is my parish.
Like parish meaning like the group of people
that you're supposed to shepherd.
He's like the world is, you think of the early church
who went about as they were scattered by persecution.
They went about doing what? Preaching the word
countless others today, investing their lives
for the king and his kingdom.
Like don't overcomplicate this.
This is merely taking whatever time and talents
and treasures that God has entrusted to you
and utilizing them for his purposes first, right?
He, he, this is not ownership here.
This is stewardship, right? You understand the difference.
They didn't own that minea.
That was the owners, that was the masters.
They were stewards of it.
And so when we think we own all of this, our time, talent,
treasures all of our lives, our bodies, our stuff,
then we call the shots.
If we're stewards of all of it, he calls the shots,
he directs it, he tells us how to use it
and he gives it to us
and trusts it to us for his purpose first.
And then we reap the benefits after that.
It should be first and foremost his
the way he wants to use it.
And then we get whatever's left over
which will always take care of us.
Don't think he's not going to.
But you see the principle,
the way those change our mindsets, right?
And what we do is we invest for his kingdom is we trust him
for whatever profit he wants to bring outta that investment.
'cause the work is his. He brings the fruit, not us.
We are called to invest.
He brings whatever fruit he wants, it's his ministry.
That's our assignment believer.
That's your assignment is to invest in the kingdom of God.
And also see here
that your reward is contingent on how you do that.
Your reward is contingent on how well you do that.
You saw the different reactions that the king had
to the different servants, right?
The first one turned one into 10, verse 17, well done.
Good servant. You've been faithful in a very little,
you'll have authority over 10 cities.
Now we don't know what that means fully,
but all it illustrates is
how extravagant God's reward system is, right?
Like you can't buy one city
for $80,000, let alone 10 cities.
And somehow this king is just like, yeah,
here's all the authority over these.
Like, whoa, we have to think through how amazing
and abundant God's reward system is.
There's a second servant turned one minus
into five, similar response.
Verse 19, you'd be over five cities.
Now here's, I, I mentioned the parable,
the talents in Matthew 25 earlier.
This is where it kind of balances out a little bit
and it adds a better element I think to this
because the master in that parable responds to both
of these first two servants identically.
He says the exact same thing, which we can kind
of imply here in Luke 19,
that he would've said the same thing to the second.
But it's explicit in Matthew 25 verse 21.
He said to both of those two servants, well done,
good and faithful servant.
You've been faithful over little.
I'll set you over much enter into the joy of your master.
So here's the point. It didn't matter
what those two servants started with, all
that mattered was their faithfulness.
You've been given five, you've been given
two, you've been given one.
It doesn't matter. Just be faithful with
what you have been given and they got the exact same
response from the king.
So here's what I, what I'm getting with this.
You should not worry about what other believers are doing.
Now, in one way, I listen to what I'm saying.
Yes, we should care about each other, but,
but we should not play some comparison game
between spiritual gifts.
You have an audience of one. You are to use your gifts.
I'm to use my gifts solely.
Paul says this in in the pastoral epistles.
He's like, my goal is to please him. That is all I'm about.
So I have to say something that's hard,
have a hard conversation.
I have to, to lead towards something that is he pleased.
That's my goal. Same for you.
It doesn't matter what he's entrusted to you.
Maybe he's gonna work through somebody publicly more than,
than he would through you.
Praise God. The kingdom's growing.
You be faithful with what he's given you.
This, this is a little harder.
What if God chooses to work in massive ways
through another church in our city?
Praise God. Because the kingdom is growing, right?
And we be faithful with what he's given us.
That's all we do. All our job is to be faithful with
what he's entrusted to us.
If he's choose to do something else through somebody else,
that's totally his call.
It doesn't matter. Our job is to look at him
and say, are you pleased with this?
And we be faithful with our assignment.
You be faithful with your assignment.
Whatever gifts and abilities
and opportunities God has entrusted to you
with your neighbors, with your workplace, with your skills,
with your financial ability, whatever it is,
whatever God is entrusted to you, you be faithful with that.
And God will bless that. That's the whole goal here.
But if you remember, there was one servant in the parable
who was not faithful, right?
Looking in at Luke 19 verses 20
and 21, this is the third servant.
He came saying, Lord, here is your mana,
which I kept laid away in a handkerchief for.
I was afraid of you because you're a severe man.
You take what you did not deposit you, reap
what you did not sow.
Now remember something before the king left,
he explicitly commanded every one of them
to engage in business until he returned.
He said, go invest this minor to all of 'em.
Now think about this. This guy was a rich man.
He was a noble man. He was, he was a businessman.
He knew how this whole thing worked.
So he would've understood
that sometimes the deals don't work out, do they?
Sometimes you invest the one min and you get none back.
Sometimes one gets 10, sometimes one gets five,
but sometimes it's no return.
So really this servant had no way to fail.
No way to fail if you would've just tried.
In fact, that was the only way he could fail, was
to not even try.
I frustrated the king, obviously.
And so he took away the unfaithful servant's minor.
This, this servant was scared that he was gonna lose it.
He lost it. Anyway, listen,
if you never use God's gifts
to serve other people in the church, if you
aren't giving generously with what God has entrusted
to you financially, whether that's a whole lot
or a whole little, it doesn't matter if you're not giving
generously to what he's entrusted you.
If you don't ever talk about Jesus with other people,
you are doing the same thing.
This third servant did.
You're taking the owner's minor
and you're hiding it in a Kleenex.
But, but I'm scared to lose it.
I don't, I don't know if I can, I don't.
I don't know what to do. I don't.
I don't have those gifts that you do.
I, I don't have as much money as they do.
I don't know if I can. I don't really wanna lose it.
I'm gonna mess it up. I know I am.
Again, see it.
If you don't invest,
if you don't even take a step towards investing,
if you don't give an effort towards investing
what God's entrusted to you, you're wasting
what God has entrusted to you.
And he says, bad steward of the kingdom.
And eventually you'll end up losing those gifts.
You can't lose salvation. You're already redeemed.
But what he's entrusted to you that he wants to use,
as two Corinthians five said that,
that we are the vessel he's using to,
to proclaim this message.
You lose the opportunity to be a part of that.
And I know it sounds kinda harsh,
but did you see the underlying urgency in this parable?
Did those servants know when the king would return?
No. They had no idea. And so they had to get
after the work immediately because they,
if they were being good servants, good stewards,
they didn't want to be caught empty
handed when that king returned.
So they're like, we gotta get after this.
We gotta go work to, to invest what he told us to do.
We gotta obey now
and we wanna maximize his return, don't we?
So let's get in. Let's go, go, go.
Your time is coming too.
Your assignment is clear.
Your reward is contingent on how you do that.
And the time is coming soon when you'll be held
accountable for how you did this.
What I will be standing before Jesus
and I will give an account for how I used everything
that he gave me to use.
So many of Jesus' parables are about being ready
for his return, keeping the lamps lit,
staying awake all night, like, be ready
because you don't know when it's coming.
It's similar here that yes,
we've been freed from judgment if we've trusted in Christ
as our savior, but he's calling us to faithfulness until
that kingdom fully comes
being a good steward.
Listen, think about for these people who are hearing this
for us today, to hear this message
of the kingdom is not only a privilege,
it's also responsibility.
And we will be held accountable for what we do with
that kingdom ministry kingdom message
when he returns and what?
What are you gonna do when he comes back?
You're gonna bring your $5 back to the teacher.
I was scared to lose it, scared to mess it up.
Or will you invest all that he's entrusted to you,
uniquely different than me, different than her,
different than him, uniquely what he's given you
to do for his kingdom.
Will you invest that with your whole life, trusting God
to bring the results that's not up to you but you invest.
Will you do that instead?
I love what the old hymn says.
Only one life will soon be passed.
Only what's done for Christ will last.
And when I am dying, how happy I'll be.
If the lamp of my life has been burned out for thee,
may that mark us as individuals, as families,
as cgs, as a church.
May that mark us.